thank you and we're back at George
Washington University to continue the
discussion on the national security
archives 20th anniversary this afternoon
discussion on confidential sources
sources and how we cover these issues in
the future we have a tremendous group of
archive friends fellows and about three
Pulitzer Prizes among them on the panel
I like to ask Geneva over holtzer
Pulitzer prize-winning editor of the Des
Moines Register ombudsperson at the
Washington Post distinguished professor
of journalism University of Missouri and
our moderator today of the journalism
panel I'd like to ask sigh Hirsch to
come on ups sigh who has a brand new
article in this week's new yorker
magazine about the coming air war in
iraq and has done some of the most
extraordinary reporting scott armstrong
the original visionary founder of the
National Security Archive formerly the
Washington Post now with information
trust and Tina Rosenberg one of my great
proud moments one of the best decisions
I ever made was to ask Tina to come sit
in our office as a fellow while she
researched and wrote the spectacular
book haunted land facing Europe's ghosts
after communism they won the Pulitzer
Prize our distinguished panel I will let
you take it away Geneva thank you I want
to just remind everybody at five o'clock
the bar opens upstairs it's a great
honor to be here with you and to chair
this panel as you can imagine Tom
honored me by being a part of a panel
last March that we call the seduction of
secrecy he was one of as I recall 24
people on that round table and i must
say i find this 3some more daunting by
far so it's great to be with you and
what a remarkable time it is I'm sure
you'd all agree when we gather here such
powerful public events and such
remarkable changes in so many of our
institutions including of course the
press our panel will begin with some
thoughts
from psy about the current
administration and what it's up to and
how it got here I think those would be a
nice follow-on to the previous panel and
then we're going to move to Scott to
look back over these 20 years for which
you've had significant responsibility
and think about where we stand in terms
of secrecy and accountability and then
move on to Tina who will take us to a
broader stage with looks at
International Journalism so sighs I sort
of feel sorry for the archive because I
think you know this administration
certainly isn't going to help your
business as far as I can tell I've never
seen a group that doesn't commit things
the writing does things orally
particularly and some of the stuff going
on with the prisoners the rendition
issue I don't think we're going to find
a lot of paper about you know the issues
involved and basically I've come down to
the point where I just sort of go back
to being and I was a police report in
Chicago for a long time and I think
maybe that's just a basic way to look at
this but perhaps one way of looking at
this administration is to say um just
make an assumption sort of a heuristic
assumption that whatever happened with
the FBI and the Patriot Act after the
911 incident when the FBI got everything
you wanted just go expand that and just
imagine you're inside the black covert
community and just assume that just as
the FBI made an enormous strides in
acquiring new rights and new abilities
in terms of intrusion and violations of
the Constitution I would argue in terms
of the day-to-day life for our citizenry
just assume that and on the covert side
of the world there was this huge sort of
grabbing of authority to and then you go
beyond that assumption about which I can
tell you who knows much because it's all
wrapped in in this is a government
that's gone extraordinary lengths in
terms of in the Pentagon they set up
what are we didn't know many years ago
the word SAP special access program was
a most highly classified program that
was really in the Pentagon that was
meant earlier initially for technical
collection programs stealth bombers and
stuff like that the predator
are you wanted to be sure to keep this
in sort of sacrosanct secrecy and now
it's been expanded certainly to the
covert war against anybody we don't like
anywhere in the world it is sort of
remarkable that we think we have the
right to go into any country in any
house in any bedroom pull somebody out
in the middle of night by their hair and
drag them onto a plane and fly them
somewhere we do think we have that right
now somehow we think 911 conveys that
right it's not a it's not a value shared
by everybody but anyway and if just look
at the one getting back to the notion of
a police reporter the question is what
was the intent of the finish up with the
SAP the specialized expo programs now
these kind of programs that initially as
I say we're meant for technical
collection got involved in rendition and
the grabbing and now it's my friends
tell me it's out of sight inside I mean
the exponential growth in special access
programs makes it very hard for even
those few people in Congress and they're
very few who want to investigate most of
them are Democrats and they can't get
the committee chairman to listen to them
but even if they do try they're wrapped
up in this enormous secrecy that you
know in the SAP just mentioning a SAP or
the code word for a sad bird if it could
use your clearances if you're inside but
above and beyond all that which makes it
very difficult to operate certainly even
even as a sworn all clearance given
investigator for let's say the Senate
Armed Services Committee if you're so
wanted to you couldn't find out much let
alone being a reporter we're at the
shreds but above beyond that so what was
the intent of the people in the black
when they searched all this power that
we don't even know about I assure you
that I think if we knew everything we
could understand some of the Gonzales
and some of the other Lou memo some of
the memos that seem to be so
off-the-wall I think we could understand
them in the context you can't possibly
understand them particularly some of the
early 2002 con memos I think you can
only understand those in the context of
what else was really going on that
nobody knew about and you had to prepare
for and I can tell you there was a
tremendous fight inside over language
and who's going to be authorized
specifically and of course nobody wants
anything in rat
language so you always have the problem
no language really ultimately and you
know I've had people in the black world
in the dirty side of the black world
young kids who do things for which
they're not proud say to me thank God
you know there's no Democrats running
the senate armed services committee
because if there was an investigation
out my ass would be out there I'm be
trouble because there's no authority for
what I've done so what was the intent of
the people in the covert world that we
couldn't see what was their intent in
formulating let's say the equivalent of
the Patriot Act in the black world and I
think the intent was to and his where
you get into a criminal activity
potentially the intent was to over evade
and ignore and undercut the the
legislative right to the Senate and
House Intelligence Committee is there
there / KHOU visits in terms of looking
at intelligence the intent was to avoid
any sort of congressional oversight or
to find ways to evade it the intent was
to get out from the thumb of any sort of
external supervision and that I propose
is not an honorable intent and that's
where you know in a perfect world if we
had all the papers we could probably go
to work if you were a bunch of young
aggressive attorney general's deputies
Attorney General's so there you are i
think i think the bottom line is one
we're never going to get to it's it's
there's a dirty secret war out there
with secret 30 authorizations about
which we know nothing and the intent of
which of this government is very suspect
and it's pretty daunting i can only tell
you that that inside this awful world
are a lot of people that are very
troubled by it more than you might
imagine because the wonderful thing
about America is that the people that do
their daily work whatever it is want to
think they're doing the right thing
before we move to Scott I want to ask
you something about that sigh is the
number of people say mid-level career
people who want the word to go out about
what's going on shrinking or is it
holding steady I'm you know I've you
know why should I talk about that
because I asked you to
I'm absolutely against self-immolation
well we'll move on Scott we hope to a
more responsive panelist no I want you
to give us a sense scatter whether you
agree with Bill Moyers characterization
of this being a far more secretive
administration he talked about Michael
masson's piece in The New York Review of
Books and he gave us some documentation
zuv that certainly by number but I think
you've been especially concerned with
certain kinds of secrecy I think we're
often misled by my numbers alone the
amount of classification that occurs
during a war period of course is
increased and there it's increased by
the number of different agencies in the
number of people and the
compartmentalization that size referred
to is even more important but largely I
think things have changed in terms of
the way people treat secrecy it's it's
the purpose of secrecy is generally
thought national security secrecy is
generally thought to be a focus on
keeping a hostile enemy or terrorists at
bay and in fact I think if you look at
the practical side of secrecy and you
look at the way it's developed over the
last 20 years what we find is that the
hierarchy is considerably different the
most energy in government from largely
political actors but also from
bureaucracies is to keep information
away from the press and the public the
second most amount of energy goes into
keeping it away from the Congress and
now of necessity the judiciary the
third-most goes from keeping it away
from a sympathetic from from other
government agencies within the United
States government the army doesn't want
the Navy to know what it's doing the
difficulty some of its
compartmentalization some of its not
wanting to expose oneself some of its
sheer competition for budget mind share
and so forth the next category are
allies we try and keep things away from
very sensitive things that that often
occurring on their own territory the
next category i would say it gets less
attention that all of the above our
hostile nations and then there are
terrorists now that doesn't mean that
there aren't sick
things going on that doesn't mean that
that there aren't things that need to be
kept secret but things have not changed
dramatically since I think was in in
1985 we started the archive general
Stilwell said that eighty-three percent
of what was classified didn't need to be
classified by the time that year was out
he acknowledged it was ninety percent by
the time I talked to him the next year
he said well ninety-five percent does
need to be classified at all an
administrative Lee confidential for a
short time but it's the nub of what else
is there and the fact of the matter is
it's the purpose is to control the
debate to manipulate the debate to keep
track of what the press is doing by
feeding them some things but keeping
them away from other things making it
that much more difficult Dave Jurgen
gave us that and the Reagan
administration if you feed the animals
at a certain time of day and they get
used to it in your fill their newsle
they'll go away and that's a problem not
necessarily of secrecy it's a problem
also of the way the way the press does
its business and there are very few
people who recognize how few
investigative reporters enterprise
reporters there are the cover national
security affairs sigh is one of a very
small number of people that go back and
back and back and develop sources over a
long period of time document things
piece them together I have to remember
when I came to town in in 1973 sigh ask
the question who is the right to pull
somebody out of bed in the middle of the
night and harass him well I remember
getting a call at 2am from sigh all
right I met once or twice and I was
working for the Watergate committee and
he started badgering me and said this
Woodward Bernstein of this story and I
got to match it and I know you're the
source of it I said I wasn't assoc so
well I've already talked to lens Durand
dash to the Watergate councils they've
already told me so then you don't need
me you already got to so she said well I
want to know more details it's just
anyway I wasn't the source of it he
didn't get the story but I'm sure he had
it matched it by morning and we now know
who has the right to drag people out
about in the middle of night but that's
what that is what it takes this man is a
dynamo there are other ways of doing it
there's the Trudy Miller way of doing it
which I won't try and caricature because
this is the prime time TV children might
be watching but there's there's
Woodward's seduction at the top which
gives you a particular type of of
information but it goes
back and back and back you can criticize
him for doing it at book leave things
but it yields something quite unique and
these are all source relationships in
the year 2000 many people have forgotten
we had an official secrets act was
passed by both houses of government it
sounded absurd when it was first
articulated they didn't really have any
public hearings on it they did it by
having the house do something and then
the Senate hadn't done a thing and then
incorporating it at council at
conference into the bill and taking it
back to the Senate and passing it and we
all kind of woke up when it happened on
a Friday the 13th those remember these
days we woke up that next Monday morning
to the news stories that were reporting
in wanting stories that both houses of
Congress had passed this bill which
those have new the build amounted to an
official secrets act would have made
things would have made it a felony to
talk about virtually anything that was
ever classified or classifiable it was
in perpetuity would have governed mort
today he would have to go get permission
to go back and Walter to talk about
these things I we we lobbied against it
finally the Prescott could have
struggled up to their knees and almost
onto their feet to to act like a like an
institution that was viable and and they
went in and lobbied and they made a
presentation and then we were told by
the chief of staff John Podesta that we
hadn't made it if the president's going
to sign the bill the night before
signing the bill we had a meeting with
the Attorney General who've been a major
major shift now this is a Clinton
administration remember attorney general
Reno's staff everybody but her all the
deputy secretaries are the the the the
Deputy Attorney General the various
Assistant Attorney General's about 30
people in the had to get a group at the
very last minute got Ben Bradlee and
Bill kovitch Bradley did his best
imitation to Jason Robards talk about
the Pentagon Papers and it wasn't
getting them anywhere bill focused in on
the practical implications of what
happened which is what they didn't seem
to understand if you start not only just
classifying everything that's already
done but you start actually applying
strict measures non-disclosure
agreements you start inquiring taking
people for grand juries start doing
these things you're going to
totally control the national security
world because the daily journalism of
national security involves because
everything's classified involves
discussing things even though they
shouldn't be with people if you're doing
a if you're a self-respecting Pentagon
reporter and this is a calling from a
larger category to a very small group
when you hear the the the the Secretary
of Defense make a presentation you will
go to somebody who's not authorized to
talk to you are you talking to the
authorized people you're not talking to
the right people and when you go to
those people they begin to give you the
story and that's the process that they
were trying to interrupt we got a veto
as it turns out largely on the strobe
talbott one in at the last minute not on
a journalism basis but said I'd say its
government can't function this way
ultimately it rolled forward and we
started the press began a dialogue with
the intelligence community to try and
find out what it was after 20 after 50
years of cold war they finally in an
official secrets act when the Soviet
Union had fallen and and the answer
turned out to be that there were very
few things that they were concerned
about they were very specific things and
they had more to do with our tradecraft
and their trade craft and they didn't
necessarily require us to not tell the
public what was going on it was a manner
of referring to intercepts when it had
time place date and certain language in
it that would allow somebody to discover
they were being intercepted and that
dialogue which has been on and off it's
now about to be restarted again has been
helpful in trying to keep an official
secrets act away but also trying to show
that the journalists can if they choose
to be probing and it's the problem we're
not probing enough get to information
put it out there without damaging the
national security but that's the level
of secrecy that occurs today and is is
largely a function of what we've missed
what during the weapons of mass
destruction debate we did report and if
you piece together all the reports
you'll see a pretty good description of
what the Democrats should have seen as
well as the Republicans that there
wasn't very good evidence that this was
that this was a appropriate reason to go
into into Iraq what you don't see is and
you still to this day don't see our
discussions of the deployability of web
now what's the point of a weapon of mass
destruction it was not deployable and
becomes a doomsday device and it's when
you go back and look see some of that
with night ritter's reporting actually
they talked about the lack of
deployability which made them raise
questions about is uh Jonathan Landy and
yeah yeah and there weren't very
specific and that's we're talking about
one of the half dozen journalists it's
kind of gotten into that but the major
media this repetition and this allowing
the the soapbox that the president has
and the care and feeding of the press to
make sure that that new soul gets filled
and what they've done and I think this
is the future of where we're headed is
they've learned that by denying us the
certain tools we have I mean when we
started out we had agon phone books even
phone books from other agencies become
critical tools for beginning to work
inside and seeing how the structure
works finding a dozen sources out of 140
sources that you call that's what
investigative journalism and national
security is if you keep the phone book
away from somebody you've made it a lot
harder now it's not the world's artist
thing you get a phone book but just by
raising the threshold of everyday
journalism and by the same time pushing
out the pablum that you want to have
printed secrecy can work pretty well to
control and manipulate the direction of
the press that's a terrific topic that I
want to get back to but first i want to
bring tina into this discussion we have
been focusing this afternoon on american
journalism there's been a lot going on
tell us how much impact that has on
journalists international 18 thank you I
first want to say that I'm just honored
to be on a panel with sy Hersh and Scott
Armstrong and I am privileged to have
been associated with the archive and
thank you Tom for having me the impact
of what we do in the United States with
our journalists and our journalism is
large in the rest of the world and let's
just talk about the instant case of
plane gate from close up where we all
are looking at it it looks very
complicated but from overseas it looks
pretty simple a lot of people overseas
see it as the following which is that
the United States government has jailed
a journalist for not revealing sources p
period and that has had repercussions in
some of the oddest places one of them
Nepal Nepal had a very large crack down
on its media this year and one of the
justifications it has given and let me
quote the Nepal minister of information
and communications he was warning the
Nepalese media to strictly obey the new
media related law and requested friendly
countries not to poke their nose in and
here's what he said senior journalists
have been detained in powerful countries
but we haven't said anything does it
mean that we should also start
criticizing them will go Chavez in
Venezuela not a friend of the Free Press
has used the you Judy Miller gelling as
a pretext for what is going on in
Venezuela he has said I doubt very much
that in any other country in the world
there was more freedom of speech than in
Venezuela we will never jail a
journalist in Venezuela because he did
not want to reveal his sources here and
he was evidently visiting the u.s. when
he said this yes you have a journalist
in jail here because she did not want to
reveal her sources another place that
has been citing this as a justification
for crackdown is Cameroon they wrote a
letter to the Committee to Protect
Journalists saying what's the big deal
about Joe in a journalist for not
revealing a source many countries do it
including the United States so one of
the effects that has been little noticed
of plane gate is to give a justification
to other repressive governments who know
perfectly well that the situation is not
comparable as intricate as it is but it
gives them an excuse however I think the
problem is a little bit deeper than that
there has been over the past five or so
years a seriously deteriorating climate
for international press freedom there
are more killings there are more jailing
of journalists there are greater use
there's a greater use of repressive laws
such as prosecuting journalists for
allegedly libelous statements rather
than making it a civil case and a lot of
it can be traced back to one event which
was 911 and there's a couple of
different reasons for that it's not
really a one it's
not a clear clear correlation there's
there are some other reasons that things
have gotten worse internationally but
this is a big one um you can feel that
there is a different a different
atmosphere on this in much of the world
um and there's three different reasons
some countries the crackdown on the
press has come as part of a general
crackdown on presume terrorism and the
crackdowns on the press are in most
cases a very misguided part of that but
nevertheless they are part of that in
some countries it's just a ridiculous
excuse Robert Mugabe in Zimbabwe has
taken to calling journalists terrorists
and he started using that terminology
just after its what started to become
something that mattered internationally
after nine eleven the most important
reason though is that we have somewhat
reverted to an international atmosphere
that we had in the world during the Cold
War which is that your behavior doesn't
matter as much as your alliances anymore
and this I think is the important thing
the in the years leading up to two
thousand and two thousand one there was
a general improvement in the climate of
press freedom in the world and one
reason was that there was a lot of
international pressure on countries to
behave themselves the only countries who
really out and outward jailing
journalists in a big way or killing
journalists in a big way were those
international pariahs who really didn't
care about world public opinion that is
no longer true countries that had more
or less stop doing that are now doing it
again turkey for example is one is one
there had been dozens of journalists in
prison in Turkey and that dwindled to a
few and now that number is back up again
and pressure from journalism groups
pressure from citizens pressure from
democracy activists and pressure
internationally had a big impact on
keeping journalists in journalism free
now that is changing again because we
are now in a situation where countries
will say we don't really care about this
anymore what is important to us is our
relationship with the United States and
that we gain by being an ally in the war
on terror and whatever else we do is
going to be overlooked that of course
was an extreme during the Cold War but
we now are seeing another part
it again thank you so much Tina I want
all of you to think about this question
that Scott raised about the need for
more probing lawyers talked about this
certainly the greater need for
independence in journalism now the fact
that the administration is for so many
the single source or the dominating
source people talk about silver platter
journalism people you've mentioned
Gorgons Gorgons theory scott that if you
feed them enough you know they won't
bother you poking around for the rest of
it what can we do about this especially
given the economic challenges that so
many media are facing I'd love to hear
from each of you about that so I start
well the economic challenge challenges
are all corporate greed really am you've
got a bunch of newspapers now being
destroyed and dismantle in front of our
eyes everything that Chicago Tribune
seems to touch around the world becomes
unless a newspaper within a few years
people leave good editors leave good
reporters leave and so you have been
bagged icky and was writing about this
20 30 years ago and he's dead right I'll
just spoil the party more by telling you
this not just a question of this is a
government that doesn't like to give be
straight with the press and likes to
feed his stories i think the extent in
which they're fabricating information
here strategic deception if you will
elaborate complicated long-range
planning on to get untruths into the
news in america in violation of i should
tell you all sorts of laws for these
kind of operations is staggering very
hard to get to i'm convinced you know on
you know i know it's there i know
there's a huge big deception operation
this government's been doing for a long
time that's almost impossible to get to
but I know it's there just something
we'll get to eventually what we're
seeing now with in just recently in Iraq
with the stories about the company it
just shows you a state of mind that they
have which is they're willing to take
enormous risks the the downside of
intervening by planning stories in the
press and Iraq is that the downside is
huge because it would suggest that the
very democracy we claim we're trying to
engender we're undercutting just as that
I think as I wrote about nobody seems to
care they they have intervened in every
election this government not only the
january thirtieth election they
intervened dramatically in the election
in for the constitution of certainly in
minerva in in around mosel enormous
fraud but it's just something that gets
shrugged off it's very hard to report on
so you have a combination of this a
collective ownership that seems to be
driven by you know the newspaper
business is plenty profit you know I
don't know is one with eight percent but
they seem to want an awful lot more
they've ruined papers Baltimore Sun
isn't what it used to be I was hearing
just a few days ago about this about the
LA Times the editor 15 Pulitzer Prizes
was trivet office now you know Carol
doll running a sailing a boat somewhere
and um terrible and I'm I'm back I'm
still I still don't understand why
nobody's concerned about major
corporations only networks you know we
just take it for a matter of fact in
fact okay and there isn't i was at
something for Ralph Nader last night
something 40th anniversary of the unsafe
at any speed and he made the comment
that you know I'm just talking to this
dinner group and he was saying that 10
years ago people like Ralph and others
who cared about issues broad issues of
safety and mouth health care had a
number of forms they could talk to a
Phil Donahue they were our shows he
could go on there was serious stuff
there was the number of serious kind of
shows that in which you can get a fair
you know more than a three second you
know conversation have really diminished
and it's all diminishing in front of our
eyes I don't know it seems to me that
it's not just it's something that's sort
of out of our control but one thing that
is not diminishing we ought to recognize
on this 20th anniversary of this
National Security Archive it is
nonprofit involvement in journalism I
would say the center for public
integrity is another good example and
some have been trying to fight this
fight about how do you recalibrate Wall
Street's demands some say well one way
is that we're going to have to rely more
and more on nonprofits National Public
Radio and others is that well if you
follow national public I would you know
I would I wouldn't bet on that anymore I
you know they're going a little soft it
seems to me to NPR not nearly as good
but your standards are hard to meet so i
know i don't think so i think the
standards are one that that if there's I
think truth is a standard and I don't
think truth has to be balanced all the
time by untruths and I think what
happens in newspapers is they balance
truce with untruth because that's the
system and that's the pressure they're
under and I would say Moyer's he and i
had a comedy warriors we had a
conversation in the street the other day
and he was talking about maybe the thing
to do is to get an internet news service
or something so there's a whole new so
do we have this new panoply of media and
we don't have to rely on the newspapers
the main newspapers that seem to be
staggering around if you know i would
say that when you have a small group of
neoconservatives that steal the country
I call them a cult that have taken over
the country and they demonstrate I think
and you have a feckless military that
won't speak truth to power which it
doesn't never does you have a barakah
see that doesn't rise to the occasion
hazard we have a Congress that in any
given day you can't tell whether it's
supply know prone I say this all the
time this but is down what's left is the
media and you have to understand that we
have soul udderly failed the American
people in the last five years four years
since nine eleven in our ability or
inability that comes to grips of what
these people are doing and how they've
misled us we have not done a good job
all of us particularly the main paper
has been an enormous failure in a favor
of us we have now lived up to the
constitutional obligations we have you
said the main paper or the ring papers
the main papers I blamed in my old
newspaper The New York Times which is
still the best newspaper in America but
you hold it to a high standard Scott I'd
like to pick up in size optimistic note
we've we've come I mean with it's been
this way for a long time it's that we
rely heavily on nonprofits and always
have to get information pull it together
make it meaningful in hand as stories
now a good journalist doesn't stop there
they keep going and they break new
ground they go to they write stories
that Congress picks up on we used to
heaven for our hammer there was an anvil
Congress has disappeared there's no
anvil anymore so we look at we reach for
try and hit two hammers together in
midair which is where we are now but I
want to take this back to where this
goes back to the archives founding but
just before the period that Tom
mentioned was talking about the Central
America papers project that how all
these el salvador papers came together
the origins of it in the washington post
were a little different and this is
where i say one journalist one editor
can make a difference Larry Stern who is
one of the best journalists I would
thinks i would agree of our time Larry
had this notion he had is he stone in
one ear you guys have to start doing
more of this holding people accountable
get the record get the record right
Woodward right after Watergate stumbled
into McNamara and was told about this
whole other Cuban Missile Crisis story
and so we went up to look for it but
with the documents weren't there the
documents had to be put together who was
going to do that a guy named Bill worthy
a journalism professor at at Howard
University came into the country in
Boston had his luggage searched and had
the original documents from the
so-called spies nest the the Iranian
students that had seized the embassy
there he had been wise enough to take a
second set and and leave them in London
and those were sent to me and I
published a series that I think was a
nine-part series at the post that went
through them in detail and it was but
this was Larry stern and Stern said why
don't we do this more often and we and
we set up something called a foreign
post policy project we filed over a
thousand FOIAs 600 of them got answered
and those were the first documents the
archive ed and 450 of them were the
first pending document requests at the
archive had but it was one editor who
happened to have happened to be the best
buddy of the editor-in-chief
ben bradlee but one person can make that
difference sigh makes a difference by
himself sigh as an institution by
himself he needs the New Yorker he needs
some outlet that has the patience and
time and space to give him but that's
where we start and we have to build more
tools I think that's what the archive is
the archive was built as an
epistemological tool as a institutional
memory and it came to fruition remember
during the Reagan administration when
the institutional memory was wiped out
by every week they'd come up with a news
story it was we had already had Iran
documents Central America documents and
produced in very short order in Iran
Contra a set of things exactly the time
that Iran Contra broke and kept up with
it but it was that was fortuitous in
some ways in the other hand we were just
following our noses we were we were
collecting things and staying with it
which is what the nonprofit's do there's
no reason why a newsroom can't do the
same thing and some do some do exactly
some do now to put our morose assessment
into perspective Tina how hard is it to
be a sigh Hirsch abroad boy talk about
morose you know sigh is completely right
we should truly be ashamed of ourselves
that we have not grown more American
investigative journalists in the mold of
sy Hirsch because we have it so good we
have it so good just to mention a couple
of problems if you want to try and do
what's I does from many if not most of
the world here's what you'd be facing
and let me preface this just by saying I
serve on a jury of a group that
sponsored by Transparency International
that every year chooses the best
investigative reporting on corruption in
Latin America and the prize was designed
to help encourage its twenty five
thousand dollar prize which in Latin
America is quite a bit of money and it's
designed to encourage investigative
reporting to go on and there are some
pretty good entrance but overall the
picture is quite sad and it's not hard
to figure out why I mean here's just
some of the things first of all there's
no in most places of the world no
freedom of information laws what is
public information is extremely limited
and a lot of what is public information
you can't really get you have to you
have to people that the government
officials who should be giving it up
aren't giving it up it takes you 15
visits and and and threats and bribes
and you still can't get it in many cases
investigative reporters have to deal
with governments that are tapping their
telephone following them spying on them
let me just just mention a brief
anecdote about a friend of mine who is a
phenomenal investigative reporter in
Colombia which is one of the most
difficult countries in the world to do
this his name is Fabio Castillo and he
was writing a major story for Colombia's
second newspaper el aspecto Lord about
the man who was the double Minister he
was the interior minister and the
justice minister and an incredibly
powerful man in the current
administration although Minister landoni
is not there anymore it was a potential
corruption issue and Fabio went to
interview him he had been trying and
trying to get an interview with the
minister and finally right before the
piece was supposed to go to press he
went to interview him and lon donya had
a copy of the draft of Fabio story
sitting on his desk before it was
published um this is this is not
shocking i mean it's it's horrifying but
it wasn't surprising then you have to
contend with the problems involved in
possible prosecution for libel the
United States has extremely extremely
fortunate libel standards to protect
American journalists in some places in
the world even truth is not a defense
you can be sued even if you write a
story that completely turns out to be
true and you can prove so in court how's
that for a chilling effect there are
many places where you are prosecutable
criminally you can go to jail not just
paying fines but you can go to jail if
what you write is found to have attacked
the honor of an institution and it I
need not tell you that many of these
institutions don't have that much honor
to protect revealing state secrets
extremely broadly defined some places
even treason and trees
is defined as anyone who says anything
bad about the government that can be a
treasonous offense in many cases there
was a there's a lawsuit going on in
Thailand right now one of the cabinet
ministers has sued a newspaper for 240
million dollars for defamation that is
something that's going to make a
newspaper think twice their purposes of
course are too close newspapers that
would dare to print anything that isn't
just a government handout so not only
can the reporter go to jail but if you
write a story that displeases someone
your newspaper can be closed and or
forced to pay an amount of money that's
equivalent to that in many cases your
newspaper will not back a reporter who
wants to do something that is show some
initiative or enterprise in many places
of the world most places of the world
the people who own newspapers treat them
as their playthings you own a newspaper
in order to reward your friends and
punish your enemies you don't own a
newspaper in order to to serve the truth
and why have reporters who want to get
you into trouble and that message is
obviously very quickly absorbed by the
people who work for you we're not even
starting to talk about the resource
constraint in many parts of Latin
America the job of reporters as at major
newspapers is to fill an entire page
every day what does that mean
practically that means that all you can
do is run around from press conference
to press conference and write that
politician x said why and politicians
ESET a that's all you have time to do
one of the entries we got that was in
the investigative journalism contest
from Paraguay which is a place where
it's extremely difficult to practice
investigative journalism there's a
section in the entry where they have to
talk about what were some of the
problems they faced when they were
working on the project and one of their
first issues was the cost of
photocopying the cost of photocopying
that is the kinds of resource
constraints that these papers are
working on and yet you have what seems
like an endless supply of people from
the most unlikely corners of the globe
who do try to do investigative
journalism and some of it is pretty good
our winning entry last year came from
Costa Rica which is which is a free
country and has
press but it was a corruption scandal
that ended with the jailing of two
former presidents and a third former
president had to resign a very prominent
international post so this kind of thing
does happen in many cases what what goes
under the name of investigative
journalism is simple printing of leaks
that you get from members of governments
or member or political parties in
opposition to governments you just your
job is simply to print something that
discredits their their their enemies but
you do have reporters trying to do
investigative journalism against odds
that any one of these odds would be
enough to send you back to writing about
social events but people do it and it's
truly amazing and it really should make
us embarrassed that there isn't more
really great investigative journalism in
this country where we really despite the
current problems have so many so many
advantages when we do do when we do see
good investigative journalism Scott has
talked about how the hammer needs to hit
some anvil it strikes me that in the
case of danna priests marvelous work on
black site prisons the anvil that it
struck more effectively was in Europe
rather than here what has happened with
Congress in terms of being there and
more of an active interrelationship with
the press well they did Congress I mean
it would somebody else can speak to the
to the institutional values of Congress
but what happened to Danice story in the
United States I think is very
interesting if you go back to when the
911 Commission started and during the
lunch break for the first closed session
Senator Shelby went out in the hall and
shortly thereafter a story appeared on
CNN talking about the fact they've been
an intercept on 9-10 that was not
translated till nine twelve and that
leak caused Cheney to go into apoplexy
and he called up the Chairman and
Senator Graham Democrat purportedly as
well as Senator got it as mr. Goss on
the outside agreed to have the FBI
investigate the staff for the next two
years the people that were supposed to
concentrate on the Saudi involvement in
911 we're told by the
telligence community they couldn't have
documents because they were under
investigation when dannis story ran
senator frist the majority leader and
and the and the majority leader on the
House the Speaker of the House rather
Dennis Hastert asked the intelligence
committees to conduct an investigation
of how the leak had occurred and what
happened was the staffs that were most
able in Congress to be the anvil McCain
staff Levin's staff and wax been stiff
were now told well that classified
material that you could ask us for and
then we could show you because you have
clearances we can't because you're under
investigation now I mean at least that's
the posture we don't know if that's been
applied that way but that's that's the
stage which we're in it's not just the
Congress's reluctance to do it it's a
kind of willing political manipulation
using secrecy and the the rules not
classification so much as the
compartmentalization rules to deny
people access to the things they need to
do their constitutionally mandated
function well so I that black site
prison reporting seemed to me to raise
the interesting question of how
different this war is would I mean we're
always saying you know we're not
reporting as much as we ought to be but
it seems to me in previous Wars it was
clear there were certain things we
wouldn't report on you wouldn't report
on troop movement this war it's less
clear what you would and would not
report on isn't it right well you don't
get the report on much you're locked
into into Baghdad if you're a reporter I
was talking to somebody in the the CIA
even the station they're very few people
get out of the group out of the Green
Zone somebody was telling me about a
wonderful shirt they have inside the
community intelligence community welcome
to the Green Zone the ultimate ultimate
gated community so we'll even our
intelligence operators can't get out
because of security but the world as
bush keeps saying as a broader one on
terror and the story like dennis is in a
sense of reporting on that war and would
it have happened in World War two um I
don't know I was interested that she
didn't mention the two
countries and it wasn't her doing the
editors negotiated with the white house
and left out to two countries apparently
Romania and Poland and when you could go
and search the records and see that
Poland certainly have been mentioned
many times as a repository I would say
most of the prisoners most of the
prisoners I think the CIA prisons are
when you're done with whatever you do
wherever you do it i think they park a
lot of people in those prisons that's
what they're that they're the sort of
where we keep them and poles i can tell
you that and there's no rough for a
bunch of people in the world they just
kill everybody in iraq everybody's very
impressed by the polls and there's no
question that the polls are very big
players in every game we want whether
covert overt but in though in the war
itself to polish troops which is bang
bang bang all the time and you know it's
yeah you got a war that's so at odds
with anything we've ever called war in
the American lexicon you know this this
isn't the battle for independence and
this isn't world war won a World War two
this is some insane war in which the
information we had a story after story
the other week about the interior
minister of of the jafari government
being involved in terror I can tell you
that the American intelligence community
and the British intelligence committee
have been intercepting this guy for
months talk of running death squads we
know exactly what he's doing and we've
known for a long time so there's just
this incredible sort of like you know
you bleh you to head down on the pillow
and it begins to spin because it's sort
of an it's impossible to correlate
what's really going on with what we
think is going on and what we can learn
is not there journalist tree fault
because they can't get out they can't
cover anything so you've got just this
sort of utter chaos there are
contractors people tell me who get a
contract from the government to build
the school or something and they think
they have it done by people and they get
a photograph of the build the finish
school and they turn that in and they
get paid for building the school they've
never left the site they've never did
they have no idea what's been up there
but they get a photograph they get
afterwards because nobody can go out and
take a look at it I mean I'm not
exaggerating it's beyond the can of
what's going on it's just beyond how
you're going to cope with with the world
in which I you know I it's it's just
sort of ultimately depressing there's a
more direct more direct answer to the
issue of why the europeans treat it
differently what we have here is there's
secret doctrine that the regulations the
formulation of how people are to behave
in the government is not in wide
circulation even in the government this
is the most multi-layered and so I
described the SAP characteristics of it
that's part of the reason but it's just
people do not get cut in on things they
keep them out of it and if you don't
know what the regulations are I mean we
I think we all encourage good people to
go into government because if you don't
do that you're not going to have you're
not going to have somebody to tell sy
Hersh what's going on but he's talking
to people that have been at very
specific sites at the other end it
doesn't float up through the system the
way with the way it might have in an
earlier period but nobody told the
Europeans that suddenly their their
European Bill of Rights that their that
their human rights were somehow put
aside because the Americans were in Iraq
so from their point of view they have
the right to learn this and what they're
finding out is that one or two people at
the top of their government's
intelligence chief and maybe a chief
executive we're told about these these
renditions and the use of their
facilities and by the way those
facilities are identifiable they've been
in the press as as a forward base
operational units they were just
described for other purposes but that's
where these things are so it wasn't hard
for people to figure it out but they're
now going to have to conduct an inquiry
that we apparently are unable to conduct
either in inside the executive branch
even an inspector general can't get the
right information or externally have
Congress look into even even a close
committees like the intelligence
committees seem to be either unable or
unwilling to take a look at those issues
even though their fundamental violations
of the Constitution because they're not
being told what's going on except in a
few people on very small
details that suffice for the for the
overall plans Tina well I it's it's it's
ludicrous to me that we could be
discussing how Congress could be part of
the solution on this I mean we have a
one-party government at the moment
Congress is a totally subservient to the
White House and there's no independence
there and I think as long as that holds
there is no way that that we're going to
have any sort of attention to the real
issues from the US Congress there will
be an election will tur they haven't
been set aside other things I don't know
I have one more question and then I want
to open this I'm sorry I'm just want to
say one one other thing I mean I think
there's also you went there's something
that happens to any country when there
is a war going on and when you feel like
you're under siege and we have fallen
completely into it we are in a haze
we're in slightly less of one than
before the president's popularity
numbers started to fall but we're still
in a haze and there is still I think in
the press and in many many probably most
every institution in the United States
in some way a sense that we you don't
want to raise too many questions about
this it's it's wrong we should not be in
that haze but we are still in it and the
press is still in it and Europe is
clearly not still in it especially a
Europe that now has George Bush to
confirm all its preconceived notions
about how America works let me just
raise one caution about Europe and of
course they're completely right to be
doing this investigation but they they
can take this a little far I mean I've
been to meetings in Spain where I would
say a majority of the people of the
audience present firmly believed that
the CIA attacked the Twin Towers I mean
they there is not there is sometimes
somewhat of a departure from what I
perceive to be my reality anyway on some
basic issues sure that's a good caution
Scott you mentioned bill kovitch he as
we talked about the other day
had this fairly clear feeling about
returning to the subject of reporters
leaks sources that given the fact that
we really don't have a federal shield
law one should assume that reporters
will go to jail and that in recent
events one might have assumed they'd
have gone to jail in significant numbers
I'd like to hear all of you on that
topic would you have assumed has has
taken a departure you would not have
expected our waivers a new concept what
is it well it's spun out of control more
quickly than I think anybody understood
and this little bit of history might
might bring it into focus Branzburg was
written by Louis the concurrence that
made a majority was written by Lewis
Powell and it had in it what Powell
apparently thought was a statement that
said reporters won't be taken before
grand juries to be asked about their
sources but they're otherwise you know
it otherwise depends on a balancing test
that vague language which I think was
his first if I recall right was his
first term and you might have been
somewhat manipulated by some of his
colleagues including the person justice
white I was writing the majority that
was codified then by attorney general
leaving and a rather specific set of
arrangements that were meant to you had
to take the issue to the Attorney
General before you could go out and go
after a reporter and for many years that
served us pretty well and their
organizations that have made sure that
that we were aware of that the reporters
Committee Lucy's here today Bill's group
the committee and concerned journalists
and other groups that have a S&E and
other groups that have focused on this
but suddenly we were faced with a
prosecutor who hit who had been a 911
prosecutor and while he was doing the
911 prosecutions he had a leak occur
that prevented him from his affidavit
says from conducting a raid to get
materials it interfered with the raid
and certain materials were removed from
the premises of one of the group called
the global relief organization and on
and that that is it turned out the raid
was coordinated with another raid in
Bosnia and this interrupted leaks
interrupted it because Judy Miller and
Phil Sheanon from the New York Times
called and basically said you're under
investigation how does that feel that
supposedly was the first time they
learned to that and then you're about to
be rated what's it like to be rated we
haven't been rated yet well let us know
now those statements turn out not to be
true you check the chronology the but
that particular us assistant US attorney
suddenly becomes the US attorney in
Chicago complete fluke because senator
Fitzgerald departing from the Senate in
Illinois can't come up with a candidate
he asks the white the Justice Department
which then James Comey had come from the
US Attorney's Office Southern District
to become deputy attorney general for a
name they said well if we give him
something named Fitzgerald at least to
be able to remember the name so they
nominated Fitzgerald he becomes the
Attorney General there and takes that
grand jury case trying to get Judy
Miller and Phil Shannon's New York Times
records and that's the first and and
that was met and that was actually that
case was successfully won under a
Branzburg interpretation but Fitzgerald
then begins becomes the special
prosecutor he is not the press has given
him a free ride much more ideologically
committed to changing the way these
things work he says that the leavey
guidelines would have been met but he
says leaving islands don't apply to him
anyway so he went ahead and the next
thing we know we have people ranging
from mr. weekend news Tim Russert
cooperating you are bound to cooperate
in the sense of having a dialogue but
you're not necessarily bound in the
sense of testifying it doesn't that
doesn't make good sense and what's
clearest of all is that this is not a
transactional relationship it's not one
source and one journalist it's not like
attorney-client or like doctor/patient
it is a series of relationships
involving many sources often many
reporters in the same newsroom often
many editors and if you begin to think
of it in those terms it's a big deal to
allow somebody to wave it in the opinion
that that ultimately came down against
at times one of the judges are writing
is concurrent
says that you can't have a free waiver
there is no such thing as a waiver and
so what we ended up with however was a
gossip columnist for Time magazine Matt
Cooper went in and and immediately
testified now nobody's particularly
surprised about that that's his job to
get the latest that week's gossip from
the White House but it gradually rolled
forward and when Judy finally
capitulated in quite the right word
format Cooper's testimony right
immediately to well when he was finally
after the first round of discussions
that he went in my life I he I want to
get the other well and and and Judy did
hold out now Judy was protecting a
source in retrospect it looks like she
might have been the source that she was
protecting but that it's rolled further
the only way we're shield law would be
great if we could get it for what's
important the National City reporting
there's going to be an exception
exception has been drafted as narrowly
as people can but it's going to get
washed away we're on the hill two weeks
ago and mr. Huxter said well how about
if we get an official secrets act and
you get a shield law yeah so Abbi I they
actually don't really want an official
secrets act and I don't think they'll
get one but that's the that's the kind
of thinking that's going along with it
cabbages point is there's only one thing
you should do you just don't go testify
it's a matter of civil disobedience and
once that's clear they're not going to
keep throwing the best journalists in
America in jail one after the other side
no I don't talk about it okay that was
quick Thank You Tina I wouldn't be so
sure that that they wouldn't keep
throwing the best journalists in America
and gel one right after the other all
right that's a good note to bring the
audience and on isn't it if you would
approach the microphone here is it's
switched on I guess so and join in our
discussion
hello I asked this question of mr.
Hirsch several months ago in Baltimore
as I was writing a book about war
correspondents and their increased
danger danger of kidnapping torture
murder and the rest by both insurgents
and apparently at the hands of coalition
forces what I'd like to know is what can
be done I'd like all of you please to
comment what's going on here with
journalists apparently being targeted
and what can be done to protect them
well clearly I could just talk about al
Jazeera we need a lot more reporting on
that story and I would just offer this
thought that you don't have to use
kinetic means to destroy al Jazeera
which I mean by that a bomb this
government has an enormous capability a
classified capability to do all sorts of
ways to keep people from getting things
done in terms of going on the air so I
don't think we know everything there is
to know about the hostility of this
administration told al-jazeera and when
the beginning of the war and about
individual journalists we all read the
stories i would i would not want to be
in iraqi journalist in in in in in that
country because the American that the
belief seems to be pretty widespread
among the American military that the
journalists if you speak Arabic in your
Muslim and you're a journalist you
you're working with the insurgency which
by it the way is a strange word to
describe the vastest and Sunnis who live
in the country fighting for their own
homeland I don't know why they're the
insurgents but we'll never get were
changed it seems to me the insurgents
might be people coming into the country
bombing them they might be the
insurgents but in any case that's a
battle we tried to fight Vietnam about
the Vietcong we kept on used to
arguing that the Viet Cong Vietnamese
communists muslimah nationalist anyway
we call him the enemy I there's no
question that Muslim and Arab is
speaking journalist for the journalist
for the Arab networks and are under
tremendous duress and what you see in
America again even despite this
tremendous in the last four or five
months wave of much more skeptical
reporting there's been a huge wave I
mean we're we're not where we were six
months ago on this war and at the public
maybe the emitted maybe the press are
following the public or not but you
still see every day when I talk about
the air war in that piece and in New
York or what happens is you'll see a
story that come the American the
American community in Baghdad which is
this narrow community they can't do any
independent reporting for which they
can't be blamed you'll see a story
saying there was another attack in the
Ambar province up near Syria and 70
insurgents killed and that's in the
newspapers and then if you bothered to
look at Al Hayat which is a very good
newspaper published in around the world
didn't headquartered in London the air
paper home by this the Saudis put quite
confident al hayat and if you looked at
some of the other networks that besides
al Jazeera the other many networks
photographs of woman and children
flooding hospitals you know I don't know
who's the you know 70 insurgents killed
is in the newspaper then you see
pictures of woman and children who's
getting killed who's getting bomb why
are we doing it in that story I wrote
the other week I wish I'd done something
I used the statistic one marine air wing
from one marine air wing in the only
report we all looked in New Yorker for a
long time for any statistics the
government's simply not reporting
anything about the air war and now that
they're not giving any statistics no
sorties no tonnage we have no idea what
is growing it ekron you know
exponentially or not which one thinks it
must be one air wing in the fall of 04
last year said that from the end of
summer probably i would guess let's say
September through November 15 months
from the September 032 November 04 a
marine air wing which flies Coast close
combat support they're dropping mostly
500 pound bombers bombs dropped 500,000
tons of ordnance assuming all of those a
500
bombs and most of them were you're
talking about 2 million bombs dropped
between oh 3 and 0 for x 1 air wing when
you know the Marines are not the only
people flying we have air bases air
force bases and we have Navy doing a lot
of flying no embedded reporters no
statistic no interest in as far as i can
tell anybody pursuing this sort of
tremendous air war that's going on and
it's a war that's largely urban and so
we're doing an incredible amount of
urban bombing it seems to me maybe i'm
wrong but it seems to me the logic is
compelling we get no statistics no
pressure on the government so it's bad
to be a reporter in iraq and it's i
think almost every aspect of this war is
beyond our Ken that's all I think I just
want to quickly mention it's not only
the Arab media in Iraq who have been
detained in the last according to the
Committee to Protect Journalists so far
this year there have been at least seven
cases that we know of there's probably
more but we know about seven Iraqis
working for CBS Associated Press Agence
france-presse and reuters who have been
detained they were photographers or TV
cameramen they've been detained for
basic for doing their job for being
journalists either because the US troops
were suspicious of the photos in their
camera or they were taking pictures of
the wrong thing now I guess it is
possible that some of them were
legitimate just because you're
journalists doesn't necessarily mean
you're not doing something else also but
in this case if there is evidence we
don't know about it and they they don't
know what the charges against them are
and they've had no access to counsel
that there are it's hard to be upbeat
about your colleagues who are in danger
a constant basis but there are some
examples of something that I think has
to be examined I mean sigh met Reverend
Al Jazeera but on the American side
there was a journalist too sigh and I
both know named near' Rosen
who basically went embedded himself for
the insurgents in falaysia and he was
there during the fighting and they
understood he was an American the our
principles are our goals truth to do it
transparently and to be able to do it in
a way that it's self correcting we're
always looking back on it and his
reporting had those characteristics do
it since then he's written an op-ed
piece which has gotten him into
difficulty because he's taken a position
that's deemed to be too sympathetic by
some people in the American media with
with the with the insurgents the term
that is appropriately criticized al
Qaeda has also at a very at one period
of time made people available and
actually did this is prior to 911 did a
lot of educating and you remember
Jonathan Miller went out and met with
bin Laden on that but there were other
things that they did they were open for
business in the sense of in the sense of
trying to get their point of view of
cross it didn't result in much and it
didn't result in much that was that that
showed their concerns about the Saudi
royal family or the effect that the
United States approached the soil royal
family had in the world of Islam it
wasn't and they felt accurately
truthfully transparently reported but it
does raise the question as to whether
there isn't something else can be done
there but not without danger enormous
danger from in some sense both sides hi
just to take up the issue of what can be
done to encourage more investigative
reporting on national security subjects
one thought that occurs to me of sort of
an analogy to something that Tina and
sigh and Scott know all about is that
for the last decade and a half the
National Security Archive has been
collaborating with the Cold War
international history project at the
Wilson Center to get the other sides of
Cold War history to get away from an
American centric view and narrative of
what happened during the Cold War
strikes me that there should be a lot of
room for mainstream media and other
media to enter into collaborative
relationships with foreign media that
have a lot more language expertise
access to foreign records access to
governments that aren't beholden to Bush
administration standards of secrecy to
what extent and this could also address
resource issues language expertise
issues to what extent are traditional
competitive instincts
inhibiting the possibility of better
investigative journalism I don't think
that inhibits anything I'd be surprised
if site doesn't get several calls a week
from that I mean I I never see by lines
in The Times the post the le haga this
is a joint investigation with a French
newspaper in Italian newspaper a
Japanese publication when you know you
would think that there are probably a
lot of things that could be dug out if
there was more imagination put into okay
if we're determined to match every
single wire story on every one single
white house briefing how can we get more
people into the mix to get into some
serious journalism Tina do you have any
thoughts about that um I don't think
there's enough time left in the in the
in the fiscal year to start explaining
the times arcane rules on on by lines
and collaborations but it's a newspaper
that jealously guards it's the byline
and probably to jealously but there may
be more room for that at places like The
New Yorker for example well I certainly
deal a lot with as you can gather I deal
a lot with I do much better overseas and
I do here particularly in often on the
intelligence side so I do a lot of
reporting there and you have some
wonderful stuff that I wish more people
paid attention their Stern now has a
page would they now translating doing
good translations of their their stuff
their Spiegel rather which is a great
magazine Koretz does better stuff on
Israel any given day than the American
press much tougher and so if you don't
read her etsu you know and so you can I
think that's a great question and I
think I think that's that's a really
good thought and I wish I wish some of
the newspapers would get out of their
insane little binds but you're right i
mean i haven't worked at the new york
times for years to explain the New York
Times The Outsiders is is is a psychotic
episode I don't mean to limit today I
mean American journalism generally
missing a lot of opportunities after
that we found in doing Cold War
historical research yeah you bet Scott
excellent point there's there is
something going on which which might be
a model for this collaboration with
believing it's not easy a year ago July
Paul Clement off the
Forbes Moscow editor was assassinated
coming out of his office and it was a
hit there was no question about it they
actually have apprehended I think the
actual hitmen although the authors
aren't clear the authors of the crime
and in order to memorialize him there
was some thought well maybe
international journalists Russian and
American journalists other Western
journalists should investigate the
murder and we decided instead he was
working on things involving the Kremlin
things involving Moscow real estate
chechi and separatism Chechen corruption
the disappearance of aid to Chechnya and
Berezovsky and a whole variety of other
things as Scylla vicky's inside the
inside the Kremlin and so forth so what
we did is we came together and we have
now teamed up about four I think we have
all the wire services and probably about
10 American organizations pretty well
into it another dozen that are
interested and several dozen Russian
organizations and I think that that has
a possibility we have no funding and
what it really suggests first you have
to create a chronology and things you
have to get the materials into play and
you have to get them in multiple
languages but it's it's the prospect of
not having to rediscover the wheel
constantly because in Russia when you
start discovering the wheel you get shot
in the head and it discourages people
from shooting in the head if they think
what it does is it brings in 20 other
people and you could tell from the
Russian journalists I just had a meeting
on it on monday night that the russian
journalists feel enormously relieved i
don't know why we haven't done it yet
but just to have our participation
because it raises their profile but
they've got information will ever get
because we don't understand how I mean
Chechen you just say although Chechens
are all involved in organized crime
which is earlier where the kremlin used
to say now it says they're all
terrorists but it's a very complicated
series of stories and to get the cast of
characters right and whatnot you need
those resources and that's that's right
the foreign broadcast information
service is the is the basic
investigative reporter on international
national security affairs tool so why
shouldn't we be working with some of the
people as reporting we're already
beginning to rely upon just to add one
quick door note to this really promising
and enter
idea at the times what you'd get is the
jealously guarded thing at most of
America is almost 1,500 daily newspapers
what you'd get is local as the franchise
and very little international reporting
period and to steal a great line that
Tina told me the other day I will
attribute it we don't really have many
international stories many Latin
American stories say we have us stories
in a Latin American setting so you know
we aren't really looking for it but
maybe we can hope great idea one last
question I was going to say I have to
tell Scott somebody somebody who knows
told me the other week he gave me a
definition of the Kremlin he said well
so I just considered the largest private
investment firm in the world I was
thinking about digging into them is
going to be really tough we should keep
our answers brief to this last question
because actually I the way you a favor
I'm Steve Livingston and the director of
the School of Media and public affairs
which is the building you're in like it
after so many years of watching for
better or worse crossfire being
broadcast from that very spot I just
want to say thank you very much for
informed intelligent commentary for a
change thank
instead of crossfire you've seen Russian
roulette I want to say thanks can we
give our panelist a big round of
applause and and just before we adjourn
upstairs I just want to know one thing
which is 20 years ago the US Treasury
Department wrote to the National
Security Archive and said there is no
way that we're ever going to waive any
of these processing fees under the
Freedom of Information Act because if we
do you would turn into an unregulated
monopolistic informations are for the
entire federal government that promptly
went on our t-shirts infos ours for our
softball team and we want to present
some awards upstairs at the reception
this is an official Declassified stamp
in a historic sports trophy box labeled
on the front the National Security
Archive 1985 to 2005 infos our award
we're going to give these awards to some
distinguished people who are already
listed in your program a number of who
are right here in this room starting
with Scott Armstrong starting with ray
bonner Congressman Jim moody founders of
the archive Mort halperin the board
chairs of the archive John Shattuck Walt
slocum Joseph onic and Russell Hemingway
our board chair today mr. Chairman I
move we adjourn to the bar I would ask
you to pick up your coats from the
checkroom because we're going to be
upstairs on the second floor at the bar
and the food and thank you very much for
joining us for
yes council here didn't do it deprecated